okay i am really excited for this video
you're about to watch my best ever
performance in a lyches tyler arena
throughout the video i hit my peak blitz
rating had my best performance rating
ever
had my longest winning streak ever in
the time arena defeated countless title
players was in really good form really
focused
and i hope this uh this video offers you
some inspiration and some instructive
value as well
so before we get into the chests i do
want to thank the sponsor of today's
video which is audible so if you haven't
heard of audible they are a massive
platform of audiobooks and podcasts
and pretty much anything that involves
spoken word entertainment i love it i
can listen on the go taking walks before
i fall asleep even in the shower so let
me give you a sneak peek into my audible
library i'm into a lot of business and
self-development books
and one book that i listened to recently
that i really really enjoyed
is called flow living at the peak of
your abilities it's a book about
achieving the mental states called flow
in which you're fully immersed in
whatever you're doing
it can improve your overall fulfillment
and happiness and just effectiveness
whether it be playing chess or even the
day-to-day mundane activities it can
really shift your perspective and just
enrich your overall life
so if you want to try audible for free
for 30 days and get a free audio book of
your choice
including flow
you can use a link in the description
audible.com
i am rosen
or text i am rosen to 500 500 and i
really hope you enjoy audible as much as
i do
so happy listening and let's get back
into some chess
okay let's still gather try and stay
focused
playing cable box
i'll play london
try not to mouse up this game
we have
mainline london
yeah this is kind of a trendy line
as far as i know i'm supposed to play
a4
sooner rather than later
and knight fd2 looks a little bit
passive but uh it goes for some trade
knight c5 looks interesting
kind of double edged
it's allowing takes but
okay now i'll reroute to d3
um
[Music]
probably want to take that queen b3
i want to bring the other knight to f3
to access e5
yeah that's a move uh i think i'll start
with rook d1
there's some weird like knight d2 stuff
at some point
f6 might be played
just preventing my 95 shenanigans
yeah trying to keep some time advantage
and go for shades here
so we both have f pawn potential
i think i want to double up play f3
and target e6 eventually
you do have to watch out for knight g3
but
i don't think it's a huge problem
maybe queen b5
some idea this and this as well in king
g2
we trade
i was looking for forcing tactics but i
think i'll chill for a moment
okay that's a move
i could play queen d1
takes takes
and there's also takes
i think my
work because knight g5 h4 i win e6 and
b6 and even if i lose a4 i should be up
a pawn
hey it's jimberwood and dr dd happy 2020
2022 good vibes keep up the good work
appreciate that yeah welcome back
for those just joining this is the first
game
of the first 2022 title arena
um
try not to blunder in rook a1 i have
some king move
i should probably play h4 myself
a knight f5
it's probably okay though
i have five i have knife four
so both these pawns are hit
i want to play this and target the g
pawn
interesting
maybe g3
maybe just this
i think this is okay
neither five there's king f4
knight g2 i take on g7
[Music]
and probably go back to b7
and then f6 is hanging
ah the two's hanging
just take this
thanks so much math black mats welcome
back
i'm just trying to stay focused here
it should be winning
and time wise
now i'm throwing maiden one
no more good checks
interesting
oh so king d8 rookie works here 96
or this
okay good start
solid game
matt black matt with 2300 bits
appreciate that
what are we we're 78 years away from the
year 2300
blunderbrains
new sub
irene is here thanks irene
okay playing digiano
i think i'll stay with london
be going to london soon
so i i booked a flight to london and
then i messed i messed up the booking i
just had to cancel it
but uh hopefully i'll rebook relatively
soon
it's been so long since i've been to
london
okay we actually have a kind of jobava
london here
um
[Music]
i think a3 is actually a playable move
because if takes the knight a4 chops a
queen
point of a3 i take away the b4 square
and then
some similar idea in some game
i played a while ago queen a5 c3
i also have c4 here but
start with bishop e2
yeah i think i'll play a bit more
positionally than usual
sometimes i castle queenside go for the
kingside attack
hey eric almost a double sub baby now
happy new year and thanks for the
content hey vmg
appreciate that
maybe let's move mission d3
also some pawn maybe pawn f3
i'm preventing the
black minor pieces from doing things
some potential for queen e1 queen g3
there's a lot of potential ideas here c4
and xc5 knight d3
rook c1 to throw in
i also play b4
i'm just trying to restrict i clamp down
on the queen side
okay so we're trading a decent amount
e5 might come
like takes and then
yeah e5 is coming i think i have to play
g3
not the prettiest of moves
g4
now g3
yeah i might be slightly slightly worse
here because my pawns are a little bit
ridiculous
try this move
that's still a fight
queen d3 we trade
yeah i'm kind of accepting the fact i'm
a little bit worse
wow
this interesting move
i'll have a great way to defend
oh
i'm trying to hold on
i think f2 we might end up repeating
or not
i finally made it to the meaning of
everything hello eric oh hey
hey
42 months
oh i dropped a pawn oh that was a really
bad move too
oh no
this isn't good
i'm about to blunder stuff as well
i have to hunker down
oh no i love queen b1
opponent not finding the right moves
neither am i
let's go
let's go
my unbeaten streak continues
let's go i was the only way to survive
that i was down on time
i had to force the stalemate
even though that wasn't entirely forced
okay
hooray eric hooray
not a bad way to start the
the tyler arena
i was smelling it i didn't want to say
anything though i didn't want to jinx
myself but
the smell came to fruition
okay playing rob
i'll play a6
okay let's try and not get in a
a losing position this game
easier said than done
so we have here
some kind of queen's gambit declined
exchange variation
um i think c6 c5 might be
interesting though
i think i'll play c5 actually
yeah it's probably justified when the
knight goes here early
even
c4 b5
play c4
thank you fist bug mr swift tickle what
hath god drawed
wait what
wait let me stay focused here
trying to figure out what's going on in
this position
i think just bishop e6
white's trying to pressure me with the
minor pieces
they're all up in my face
i'm just trying to defend everything
rook c8 oh neither force coming wow
so i have knight d7
which looks to be okay
trying to trade these in these
that was a filthy stalemate
yeah i take pride in it
have to find some hand sanitizer
also have to watch my time this game
and down about 15 seconds
it looks like we'll end up trading stuff
keeping this defended by the knight
so i take with knight preventing that f4
ready to play b5
queen f5 might happen
play g6 restricting the knight
it's a move
this move
then e5
okay i think i should take
whoa let's not get triple forked
i almost allowed it to
that could've been really bad
oh no
ah
my mind is still on the previous game
this is not good
if this move
i don't think i'm coming back here
oh
at least i have a night
this pawn could be arguably weak
that's a good move though
or is it
do i'm blundering
left and right and center
very little hope at this point if rookie
won i'll uh i'll trade and
try and do the same things before
okay
at least my pawns are looking fly
i'm waiting for rookie one
that's not happening
i have to make progress
just keep pushing the pawn
and that's completely losing but
as we've seen before miracles do happen
sometimes
hey it's davina what's up davina
appreciate the raid
i'll be collabing with davina later
today actually
i think right
have to check the time
if you're just joining i am
[Music]
struggling to survive
yeah
there's no hope
or is there
ah i got maiden
okay that's my first actual loss of 2022
what to do
i blundered i blown your queen c3 i was
about to blend in i have six
g6 was maybe just a weakening move
there goes my
my reasonable score
but still early in the tournament
oh wow this is a three hour tournament
i thought it was a two hour tournament
so i'll be playing this for the next
almost three hours
opponent berserking i don't feel
confident berserking back in greek
mythology zeus was the 13th and the most
powerful god
triskaidekaphobia is the fear of friday
the 13th oh there are approximately 13
cycles of the moon each year there are
13 cards in each suit in a standard deck
of play
okay sorry that was cut off
um this is actually a really cool line
this is uh h5 is a stockfish
recommendation
and then
i'm winning the bishop actually
the opponent kind of just stumbled into
a weird
opening prep
that white probably has some
compensation but uh
yeah this is looking
quite pleasant for black
so knight c3 i'll play queen a5
feels like a weird scandy
bishop g7
undermine the bishop queen battery
maybe knight c6 coming
knight c6 hitting d4
d4 is kind of pinned to the knight which
is pinned to the king
so e5 interesting
develop
good castle here
there's h3 in the end but then g3
i think still g3 here
so i give a pawn to
prevent the h5 from opening also trying
to weaken the white king
get some initiative
i take on d4
looks kind of risky
i don't think it works
this actually isn't so easy
take and play like queen b4
h5 is also hanging
i might use to play knight before and
swing the queen over
oh wait this is a free pawn
how's the pin i didn't realize the power
of queen b6
oh is there a funny line no there's not
or is there queen g6
it's kind of a funny move
light can't be taken
but the pawn was taken
hey eric hey everyone in the chat
hey it's belgium novice
welcome back
okay uh
i feel slow today i don't know why
just trying to remember how the pieces
move
maybe this move
i think there's a line takes takes and i
win the night in the end
never mind
hitting the pawn
so e6 is kind of hanging
so i have this move
idea knight g3
oh tricky tricky
opponent didn't take my queen but okay
up enough material here
there we go
okay
yeah i feel a little bit bad not
berserking back but i'm just trying to
have enough time so i don't flag
oh yeah 8 p.m
central time tonight
so i'll probably end up doing two
streams today i'll end the stream
shortly after this tournament and then
resume
for the collaboration tonight with
davina
should be fun should be chill
of
what do i play against this
i'll play something a bit more solid c3
and bishop e2
this isn't the most exciting line but
um
there's
very like simple plans for white
a5 and queen a4
remember komski doing something like
this
so b6
makes some sense
probably worth taking
maybe even rook a6
so if b5 i have 95
queen a4
making some gains on the queen side
there's this weird move knight a5
which i'm trying to wrap my mind around
before
not happening
yeah i think i just want to triple up
and make a gun
there's also a bishop e5
it looks kind of fun
now they 5 b4 next
e4 wait a minute
yeah this is now winning material
so as we see that was like a somewhat
so-called like boring positional london
but
sometimes positional play can lead to
tactics
yeah this a4a5 push is a nice idea
okay
so 140 only lost a game
i'm not berserking probably at all this
tournament so games will be a bit more
chill
i'm playing a lot of london's
preparing to
visit uh london itself
okay jobava london time
so mainline the c5
um i'm supposed to take
and then i have three
what's the line here
pretty sure i'm supposed to take
coin a5 and then queen d2
takes knight a4 queen b4
bishop d3
there's another case where like the
queen ends up getting trapped but
not here
yeah i think i just played bishop d3
likes a little bit misplaced
i think you zip dude one two three
another new prime sub
it's like a queenside castle
that looks kind of risky though maybe
just kindy two
there's knight g4 bishop g3
it's okay
this rook
yeah trying to diffuse the diagonal
maybe knight d4 coming soon
idea knight c6
on target some weak squares
okay it might be threatening to take and
when the pawn never mind
okay knight d4
feeling good
there's some idea to double on that
never mind
black is foiling my plans
i have f4
f4 doesn't work
doe my pawn someone call an ambulance
never mind
this whole game is one big never mind
if knight f2 i would have played roger
one and trapped or trapped the knights
probably makes sense to trade everything
f4
okay now three
some
two knights against nine bishop
g4 there's e5 i don't think e5 works so
i want to play g5 and clamp down
it's going to be an endgame grind
king f3
should probably throw an a3
at some point
a3 b4 maybe
wow
that's an interesting move
i got to move faster too
position's opening up
yeah all of a sudden i don't really like
my position anymore
it should still be somewhat equal
but time-wise it's
it's definitely not easy
some knight d5 move
not sure if that does much
now the move i want to play
i want to i want to play knight g3
oh no
i might sack the knife for a pond and
try and force some vision night mates
no
yeah i was trying to get uh double a
pawns for black but not happening
wait what how am i still alive black had
made in one
wait there's lag
what just happened there
that was so weird
i don't know what just happened there
it showed opponent flagging but um yeah
there was probably just a lag
i should have lost anyway so i'm not not
too upset
there is made in one with uh b1 queen
what to do
good game
i thought i was playing for a win in the
end game that
black found some good pawn breaks opened
up the position
okay this could be a long tournament
so not seeing carlson
import nick
jungle book
the jungle book
forget who jungle book is
okay so joe bava london
i'll play this line c5
and then
it takes an a6
wow
so this is an idea i used earlier
i wonder if i can play g5 here
maybe just g6
bishop g7
thinking of knight h5
hey it's black mamba
stream thanks for the instructive and
calm atmosphere
i appreciate that
okay so
it makes sense to take
maybe it does
the idea was to remove the bishop so i
get in rook b8
not that it does too much though
might be subjecting myself to some
sacrifice
so it takes takes takes i've queen d6
maybe still holding on there
another idea is to play knight g7 image
about f5
this pawn is kind of hanging
allow white to take it
it takes with knight i take and place e5
that's actually kind of annoying
i have g5 here
g5
yeah this is not a good position
a4 is probably coming
so i'm down upon white has good pieces
but i have f6 and e5
i have an interesting shaped house
so now the point is white can it take
because the pawns tie down to the
knights
i have time for this and
the pawn storm begins
so i want to play f5
and if takes
have some decision to make
probably take with f pawn
because the rook can swing over to f7
oh that hangs h2
hmm
there's a lot of like good-looking moves
here between that f5 i think knight f5
is the simplest
idea on h3
i wanted to play queen h1 queen g1 rook
f7 but there's rook f2
and now i can go for this
and this one's a queen
or a rook
um or i'm mate this is just made in two
if king takes knight it's mate kingy
three
take the queen
okay
wow that ended kind of quickly
it turned from a really bad position to
a really good position
this f6 e5 was a nice resource
and then rook f1 was kind of panic
okay
moving up top 200
almost 600 title players playing
yeah rook f7 may have also been good but
another 5 looked
to be the the simplest
whoa i just realized i haven't
encountered e4 today everyone's been
playing d4
so no staff are gambits yet
okay i'm playing this weird line
i play this line because most people
don't know what to do against it
i temporarily stack the knight but i win
the piece back
it looks kind of dangerous though
takes is rookie one
maybe it's okay
there should be six
i'm thinking if rookie when i play this
move and queen g7 i castle queenside
gameplay
looks interesting
i'm kind of in the mood to gambit too
i've been playing a lot of solid
openings so far this tournament
actually i don't think i've played any
gambits this tournament
because i've had like london's and
queen's gambit declines
wow queen e5
it's a bold move i think i can castle
castling looks risky because this and
this but you are awesome
thanks for making the content you do oh
thank you
mr miraculous
if the bishop weren't defending the
queen i would have this move
wow knight b5
so i think i have to play bishop b6
there's also rook d5
confusing position
so rook d5
queen c7
we trade there's knight c7
i just lose a pawn at the end of that
with bishop e6 there's b4
we trade
this is actually the way to go because
b4 takes takes
uh i guess we'll find out
i have some bishop d4 move
whoa
i'll wear this proudly however what's
with all the goose stuff
that's a long story
um
i have to focus though
because this is looking like trouble
ah
queen d4 maybe
wow a lot of people getting merch
support mother goose
oh no
wow look at this move
i'm just losing now
what the move knight c6
if i take there's this
[Music]
any way to survive
i was just completely losing
i want to try and fight at least
i'll play king a8
ah no time and no position
that was a mouth slip i resigned
wow
it's a cool move though
it's like a triple x-ray fork thing
there's a lot of pins i saw the pawn was
pinned i didn't see the bishop could
potentially be pinned
so these pieces didn't actually defend
each other
yeah well played
it's hard to be disappointed after a
game like that because the opponent did
play well found some cool attacking
ideas
thank you dave's w
okay so making up to do i'll play e4
mix things up
bring it home eric even though it splits
if you imitate magnus when he goes 20 25
moves deep nobody can stand in your way
let's go
oh thanks for the encouragement
i appreciate that
okay playing uh i'm playing a reversal
limo i usually don't play with slimo
but here we are
rookie one
i mean c4 is probably coming
yeah magnus can't stand in my way if
he's not playing this tournament
i guess that's a comforting feeling
d4 maybe
why not grab the center
i just want to put the rook on d1 and be
happy
some idea queen c1
and go for some type of attack
black wants to be e5
okay
bishop d4
interesting
arguing a line takes takes takes queen
h6
um let's say f6 and then rookie three
and not
happening yeah i don't like trade queens
c3 is probably coming or not i have this
move now
threatening this because this pawn's
pinned to the queen
queen f6 is logical
i want to play d6 takes knight f5
i'm not sure if that works though
of e5 though
h6 may be coming
i feel like alpha 0 now
played this move
so idea is to remove the pawn to get to
the f6 square for the knight
um
ah it looks close
so take rook take and then knight h5
that's probably good enough so
calculations take here here here here
rookie three in the end
and then rook g3 is hard to stop
otherwise i assume if i got my knight
here it should be winning
but maybe black can still hold
there's an idea to
if i do get the knight here to play e6
and queen e5
so lock's trying to hold
i'm just trying to
keep throwing punches
i kind of miss this move but i think
that should definitely still be winning
for whites
so what's the winning idea probably
takes in in this
pretty feel good game
again nothing too special from the
opening but
got some nice middle game ideas
okay
yeah that was pleasant
yeah i think black maybe should not have
allowed the h-pawn to get all the way to
h6
we see the dangers
thanks for all the subs
not mikey zh
mental blood mr suz
palm spaghetti
yeah good to see a lot of people here
um usually during these tournaments i
don't look at chat like so thoroughly
but
i do appreciate people watching and
chatting
thank you the long diagonal
staying with the same kind of repertoire
so i'm actually playing the casa corley
variation
this uh bishop d6 combined with h6
knight knight f3 um yeah e6 is the main
line
bishop g3
play rook e8
yeah generally when the knight moves
here so early it makes sense to go over
c5
and then like c6
really trying pressure in the center
now the problem for white this this was
probably a bit too premature
but it's still playable
lingering tension between the bishops
probably want to play rook b8 if i get
the chance
debating this move
it can make sense so i want to
eventually play c5
get the pawns rolling
queen d3
point in dreaming of somehow chugging me
there's an idea of rook b4 to g4
which
looks kind of fun
imagine b3 rook before
and then the rook can kind of just chill
yeah i didn't really think beyond this
but
maybe h5
just going full out attack mode i
maneuvered my rook from a to g4
i wait lee just doesn't let me draw the
arrow
preferences
behavior
arrow
no i don't know how that got changed
there we go
okay now i'm happy again
i usually don't take move suggestions
from chats but
this would be funny to maneuver the rook
to h8
oh
okay can i sack on g3
probably not because white's in time for
92.
oh it feels close though i think i'll
play rook g5
which actually prepares
bishop f5
not sure if this works though
i might as well go for it
it looks fun
pieces are chilling
yeah i think i have to take on t2 now
i want to do crazy things but
yeah we'll simplify a little bit
there goes my amazing rook
94
it doesn't quite work
by bishop h2
h2 is interesting
i think i'll play this move i over
defend the knight and i prepare this
wow
okay so everything flying off the board
interesting i think i can take
threading made in two
i want to play rook g5
i'm just bluffing here
like yeah i could have taken that
covering the square
okay i'm going on time
yeah that would have been tragic if i
got mated on h8
okay
okay moving on
oh i haven't put together a more than
three win streak
let's try and change that
playing who dinovich
yeah so with b6 i delay e3 because
there's cases where i can play e4 and
one move
as we're probably going to see here
yeah i discovered this maybe a year or
two ago
delaying the pawn push
ooh
now maybe e3 makes sense
it kind of seems like a grunfeld now
can i win a pawn
the c7 hangs in some lines
though it might be risky to take i think
i'll play this
queen a592
queen h5
and queen a5 is still playable
yeah um
[Music]
queen d2 we trade c5 happens
i think queen queen c3 it's not the move
i'm
happy with but
just want a solid position
takes i think i have to take with knight
or take with pawn if i take with knight
there's e5
thanks everyone for subbing wow
what did the chess grand master do when
the big tournament was stressing him out
he took the knight off
i see what you did there
okay i want to play d5
d5 d6 i guess
okay so i got rid of my side pawn i
might be losing this pawn at some point
like rook d8 but now i have this move
rook e8
okay hitting the rook
confusing position here
if i take
i don't want to take play that i don't
think that works
just bishop f4
okay so i'm down the pawn but the extra
pawn for black isn't so scary
what's scary is knight c3
i have to play this move
yeah i'm gonna be down two pawns
the thing is it's not the end of the
world
we do have obstacles bishops
i want to play bishop c4
wait am i getting mated
i'm just getting mated
where did that come from
i'm just getting made it out of nowhere
oh no
most people would resign here but
please take it please please
oh
[Music]
i had to try it though
i should have said oh no my bishop
i had to use a reverse psychology
oh
yeah there's
i wanted to set up some other like
sneakier stalemate trap but
like i have to sack both pieces there
bits for getting mated you're the best
thank you so height of a nun just call
corals
oh hi
okay
well no no three-game win streak for me
i really haven't had like much of a
streak this tournament of wins or losses
let's play a game
let's play um whatever this is called
maybe e6
okay
wow
very fancy
i just take that
play f5
this is the type of thing i usually like
to do is white
probably queen e8
okay so this feels like a dutch now
i'll play
i mean bishop c4 might be coming
but i want to put the knight in g6
or for the queen on g6
still some e5 potential
although not right now
yeah i think i'm just gradually building
up we might see this in this
or that
i don't really mind though if we trade
everything then queens come off the
board
king g7 rook h8
and i'll be up exchange for a pawn
wow
so i have this move eric how often do
you face 3.d4 in the petrov
uh i faced it once this tournament
so
that's not a big sample size
you could actually check though if you
um
what do i do here
go play this
move you could reference my
me chess games
use the leches opening explorer
and then
and then see i can do it quickly after
this game if i remember
also z nation chess subbing for 51
months
the ultimate og of the channel
[Music]
welcome back to z nation
okay f4
before there's bishop h4
i think i should still go for it though
just queen g6
i want to do crazy things but
the position just calls for like simple
defending moves
and white's attack has kind of been
foiled
and now i have a potential attack of my
own
a2 is hit
wow bishop g5
that's a clever move
oh i should move quicker
if i take on e2
play this first
i think i'll go for it it's kind of
risky i'm abandoning my miking side
and now it comes down to who can meet
who quicker but i
i'm threatening some kind of force mate
and the key is there's no uh there are
no checks for white
or no good checks
there we go
yeah if i if i had to like play one more
preparatory move then i probably would
have gotten mated
um
i'm actually curious was this the best
approach
queen a2
bishop h6
okay it took a moment for stockfish to
realize
knight a4 is winning
ah knight c4
knights c4 and then knight takes c3 only
winning move
okay that would have been difficult to
find
uh real quick
just for z nation
i'll check my opening stats
in the petrov
let's see how quickly chess loads this
wait what
refresh
go
player
as black
oh wait
what am i doing
so we can see the stats here
uh d4 i've encountered
197 times
out of almost 1900 games
hey it's kasparov chess
shout out to gary
i appreciate the raid
um if you're just joining this is a
leachatory arena
the first one of 2022.
we're just checking my stats
so most people do actually go into the
the stafford statistically
anyway let's go back to tournaments
trying to break into the top 200
and then maybe eventually the top 100.
namaste eric
hey namaste tahari krishnan
also shallow took a spa of chess
actually curious who is streaming on
that channel
okay
playing tka
ever or played once before
i'll play e4 this game
and we'll go for
what do i play
play four nights
there's a funny line i like to play a3
it can be a interesting blitz opening
i'm preventing bishop b4 and one of the
points is to go into this line
and then queen e2
and
i'm actually going to just be up a pawn
yeah i have one extra c pawn
other than that the position is somewhat
symmetrical
so this is pleasant
of course it takes time to
try and grind down
and having extra c pawn
it's more like having like half a pawn
advantage
so it might be hard to make a pass pawn
later in the end game
opponent was running to take in bishop
here maybe
okay i'm gonna tickle the black pawns i
win this
always have to double check if i'm
pulling a bobby fisher but
g6 doesn't work
five doesn't work
hey thank you unknown tech
maybe i'll start with this
some h4 idea
or maybe bishop d4
some of two pawns here
oh if we trade everything there's bishop
c1 in the end then i have c4 in the end
that bishop t1 almost wins upon
what is a gifted sabbah
it's when someone
is very generous to
random people in twitch chat
okay so up two pawns up a little bit of
time
centralize the king
this should be a relatively technical
endgame
it takes patience
not in so much of a rush
but eventually i should
try and find a plan
g4
b3 first
wait let's not plunder upon
idea a5
i think i want to get the pawn to a6
alpha zero style
oh
i just blundered the pawn
oh
i thought i could play this but then
there's takes
i feel like a very weak version of alpha
zero
the good thing about being up two pawns
is that when you're when you blunder a
pawn
then you're still up a palm
that's how math works
okay let's try try this again but on the
other flank
before
not sure if trading bishops is best
let's actually play this move
it should be winning though
oh no play f4
no is it winning
it might still be winning
wow
yeah that was a weird game
um
okay got the job done
and
i thought it was really easy to convert
up two pawns but then
converting up one pawn thankfully time
was on my side
oh what's a gifted submarine
um
okay playing solini i haven't had a true
staffer gambit yet
ah or two out of two
wait what did i do
oh this line oh this line is annoying
bishop c4
i think it's knight f2
this line's really annoying
this is some like weird theory that
i'm not ready for
oh
[Music]
this line is supposed to be completely
fine for black but
in blitz
it's a little bit uncomfortable
yeah rook f1
i assume like d6 makes some sense
material wise i'm up a piece
at d6
yeah i haven't encountered this line in
a long time
many years ago i did one of these like
chess.com
it was like a guest stream it was sub
saturday
and i had this line
while streaming on their channel
i think i won the game
it's somewhere on youtube
and it's nice my opponent is taking
their time too
it's not nice that this pawn is in my
face
i think i want to play rook e8
wait but then knight no knight h where i
take it
it's weird because there's no like great
checks i cover h4
i cover these squares from the queen
with my knight
i want to deliver the first punch
knight g5 wow
i could play this move
defending attacking
actually not sure which king will end up
being
more exposed because this king looks
hideous but
so does this king
thank you bully 88.
so my threat is probably just to take
open e-file
i mean h4
think of h4i take
h5
take
then there's takes and
yeah h4
it's an interesting move i could play h5
c6 might be playable here actually
so the idea is after here i take
and then if i try some night discovery i
take the queen
is anyone in chess more liked than
yasser never heard anyone say a bad
thing about him
yeah yasser is super super kind
um
usually see him like a few times a year
in new st louis events
whoa
i can just move back though
oh then there's queen f5
i think it's still okay though
because if i take there's knight or
there's rook h1
i didn't even consider taking with king
because in queen g2 probably or g1
here we go
wow
so i have like bishop d7
f7
okay this is working out quite nicely
those up two pieces and two pawns um
probably requires some reef analysis
if we look in masters database
we followed i mean this is like a pretty
well known line
oh i actually have a game on my youtube
channel
it's like a while ago of how a nishkiri
lost in like 20 something moves
against almasi
it was like the early days of my youtube
channel
um but rook f1
[Music]
so apparently rook f1 is
not a great move
because of d6
and then
it's already
minus nine for black
okay
that was pleasant
yeah these positions can be unsettling
though
hey that's my first uh three in a row
streak of the tournament
yeah up until that game i had not won
three games in a row
and still haven't lost
more than one game in a row
oh thank you potato
g6
trying to think what uh
if i even have any prep here
because there's this move
i'm actually curious like knight c3
because i am threatening this
now i force this and we we transpose
into
what i usually get from a different move
order
but it's a very pleasant line for white
because the knight's a bit stuck on a6
it's very hard to
actually achieve a6
and chase away this knight
oh also thank you to the username with
all the h's
subbing for two
months okay so yeah i just want the
castle
probably go for 95.
positions like this are um they're
considered
like slightly better for white
but still ready for a fight
i still have a lot of tea
i only poured like one
one cup at the beginning
wait did i accidentally rhyme
accidentally rhyming is the first step
to
accidentally wrapping
c4
id2
usually like b3 is a move to play but
there's
there's takes takes and knight c3
i think i'll play knight d2
eventually go for b3
aha
so b3
b3 makes sense if takes i play rook fb1
and then the pawns defended
i'll win back this pawn
meanwhile the knight is still trying to
find some purpose in life
and there's this and
yeah
i guess f3
just preventing 94
going for h4
wow
i still want to play h4
and e5 doesn't look that great i can
also take and play
rook d1
this pawn is uh
lacking defenders
yeah throw in the check and then take
back
i want to play this move but then knight
f3
queen d3
also realizing each four would be a nice
move
essentially forcing that f7
that's a good position up upon
now up on time
got the bishop hair
got a past center pawn
whoa this rook doesn't have any squares
on the c file i'm controlling all these
squares
it's the power of having the bishop
pair you maximize square control
oh there's a funny line
queen takes g6
does it work
i don't think it works
or does it
no let's let's prepare it
uh
kind of miss that move
okay let's not be too funny though
i still want to play queen g6 there we
go
okay
okay moving up in the world
so comfortably in the top 200.
approaching top 150
are we going to see the first stafford
stafford gambit time
staffer gambit declined man
oh what to do
so i'm essentially up a tempo here which
is kind of pleasant
this is actually reverse french exchange
variation
measure d3 there's some knight before
so knight g5
not played
i'm liking the position nightwing
maneuver bishop's misplaced
[Music]
i think i'll maintain the pin
wow g4
it's interesting
yes f4 is coming
i thought i was going to be the one
expanding
the ventral f5 but
it's still interesting
probably want to go for 97.
g7 f6
i mean if f4 f6
maybe i take first
up a little bit of time
oh there's take some queen e6 check
maybe queen c7
and just rook 88.
very tense position
playing this because i might want to
play this at some point
just prevent bishop b5 ideas
the plan might be to expand
we're i feel like we're the standstill
in the center like neither of us want to
relieve the tension
95 may be coming
i'm trying to stay calm
i should probably take on d3
[Music]
so knight takes i take and play this and
hit both
pawns want to do things with at night
and discovery but
it doesn't quite work
so this defends the rook
maybe prepares not a five
never mind
maybe this move then b3
i mean
97's an idea
i was gonna say that the resulting
ending should be better for me
because the pawn is fixed on the dark
square
so i think i just want to get a bishop
ending
not so simple though
wow
i feel a little bit stuck
i'm just worse here now
maybe this saves me
maybe not
but maybe
though
you
ah
good game
oh i gotta play
um of course time was a factor but also
i think the position was very difficult
too
good game there goes my winning streak
had four wins in a row up until that
game
life goes on
so that was a staffer declined
still waiting for the real thing
we're just over the halfway point it's a
long tournament man
who's leading
jungle book is leading
playing harsha15
happy birthday
oh thank you the doctor
we're a couple months away from my half
birthday
yeah the point of h5 is uh
hoping for e3 on move three and then
there's e5
yeah i think i'll go for 95.
trying to play actively given that black
committed to such a move
when did you switch from mac to pc
a few days ago
like i got this laptop maybe a couple
weeks ago
but
streamed with it the first time a couple
days ago
um
i will say it's so much smoother
streaming on a pc than a mac
for some reason the mac kind of lags
with the streaming software
wow b5
i can't lump a son
can i sack
sagging looks really enticing
man i really want to take tape is b7c6
but then there's queen a5
i don't think it works
maybe i'll just castle
yeah just behaving myself
i'm now i'm actually threatening to take
it lock's a little bit cramped i'll play
this move still threatening maybe maybe
not though
so many things i want to do in this
position
f3 and e4
and there's also potential a4 and
eventually trap the rook
and black is really stuck here
and because h5 was played knight g6 i
take and
black has to take with f pawn
wow
if i play e4
let's not spend too much time
okay now this is a threat
i don't know if i even want to play that
though
let's start with this
okay now i'll cash in
this is just a monster bishop
[Music]
okay so i gave away my monster bishop to
be up a decent amount of material
um unfortunately i can't really defend
the pawn
i have this move counter-attacking
if this i play this running this
if it takes i'd probably take with a
rook
queen c7
oh wait h3
bishop here rook f2
your phone's just trying to flag me
um
gotta move much quicker
up a full rook here
this move like barely covers me
very barely
moving way too slow this game
you
no
queen g3 is uh the move for maiden two
ah
not fast enough what to do at least i
didn't lose that
it's close
gained a reading point
what to do it'd be like that sometimes
yeah i think you blunder champ
i could have easily lost that though
i was very fortunate to get the rook
train
yeah games like that sometimes have to
be grateful rather than
tilted
okay
life goes on
playing
lol c5
should i pre-move c5
lol
oh my opponent
my point's so clever
they forfeited the game so i couldn't
pre-move c5
lol
okay
well
that was an easy win
you're an easy clap
oh i was so looking forward to
pre-moving c5
sometimes you can't get everything you
want in life
okay playing red bwf
could you play the english next game of
course
just for you spinning siri
okay uh playing the english
i'll play queen d3
i played this move in the last round of
the 2011
k12 national championship
and i won and i got first place
um yeah this is actually an opening trap
knight takes e5
and then
actually can i can take or take
i think i can take this way oh but then
d2 hangs
probably take this way
there's knight e4 but then queen e3 i
think is okay
okay so i'm up a
pawn
i just want to develop and castle
yeah actually the opening i played and i
just played in this game
uh
the game from 2011 that was like the
most important game of my life
so it's pretty memorable
okay there's pressure on d3
wondering if flak is going to sack
okay got my answer
so queen c3
[Music]
if takes rook g1 and bishop d3 i have
bishop e3 so
i think it's okay
is opponent gonna blundermate
bishop three i could also take the
bishop but
there's no way to defend the bishop
either
there's rookie two
king e2 queen e7 bishop b3
queen e4
i'll be up a full rook though
thanks to the person who asked me to
play the english
this is working out well
yeah 27 and 24
may be coming
um that's a question how
fancy i want to be
i think 23 is actually the principled
approach
i'm just trying to prompt resignation
there we go
okay
top 150 again
back on a win streak
yeah this is a very quick wing with
english
it's nice opening drop this early queen
b3 move
it's a bit off beats
also a bit venomous
french defense when you get a chance
okay
now i'm just taking random openings from
people
playing a french i don't even know how
to play the french
there's a b4
i think queen d7
ah this line
97
i don't know this line
it's it's exchange variation so
hopefully it's not
too venomous
i know there's some ideas to castle
queenside
uh if i play this there's knight b5
which i actually might allow
because if white takes the time to
take on d6 i take back with queen
activate
should be playable stop frozen oh what's
up that is up
thanks for the bits
the kappa bits
oh
need to stretch more
okay so
yeah continuing development i think i'll
probably end up casting queenside but
oh or i just plunder upon
opponent doesn't take it
yeah let's make it sharp
it's risky
um king v8 probably makes some sense
getting off this diagonal
defending the pawn
also take with pawn here
i think i'll take with queen
so i have f6
restricting the knight
yeah typical idea g5 g4
um
this is okay because i have knight x4
wow
that move i missed
and this is probably really bad for me
now because this night is going to hang
and try not to panic
even though it's probably time to panic
the eye blender piece well played bishop
d2
i mean queen f4 maybe
trying to go all in
there's so many ways working with
material here
white's debating between taking here
first or taking here
at least they're taking time
i mean i could just pretend that
everything's okay and keep attacking as
normal
but everything's not okay
okay hitting the knight at least
those pawns hanging randomly
g4 i take the knight
also threatening to take and
maybe win something
um
queen d5
i don't want to take the pawn because it
opens a b file
hanging f6
hoping for takes takes bishop e5 and i
win the bishop
not going to happen though
i'm losing a lot of pawns here
negative six is coming
time is getting low for both of us
knight f6 is still coming man
small children close your eyes
um
let's take this
double ombissant rejected
yes let's go
i somehow won that
what just happened
oh
that's why all the young children were
supposed to close their eyes
oh
oh that was kind of dirty
g3 with a fork
oh the spike shack
also yeah somehow
that's what my opponent gets for not
taking double on poisson
okay back to tournaments
so i won a game with a french science
essay on how chess affects the brain
safe to say you're pretty smart
oh no one's ever called me smarts before
but
i'll take that as a compliment
okay trying to get into the top hundred
import some more tea as well
oh playing this person
i have a good score against this person
which means i should probably just stick
with my usual repertoire
play c3 first there's a basics i take in
queen e4
97.
there's a funny line
if casting knights e6
it might just win the bishop pair but
that's good enough for me
uh this is a really funny line
look at this line
so
the queen is trapped
and after takes takes the rook is kind
of trapped
because bishop b8
i win the exchange
uh i think i'll actually keep the bishop
be useful for later
and now queen
queen h5
the queen will probably sit on h3 after
knight of six
a point in doing things on the queen
side
i have to be somewhat careful here
it's still very much of a fight
bishop a4
i want to play bishop e8
it's not a good move though
i'll play this move
i want to play this knight e5 and f4
now my pawn tp is surviving
there's before i trap the bishop
now i can probably
start by taking
like a3
so there's a pin
wow
this line looks okay
so takes takes
we trade a bunch
essentially simplifying
queen f3
queen e3 i can't take the bishop yet
i want to play e4
i don't think e4 works
so well though
hmm
idea to maybe sack
oh no wait i have this move
maybe it's okay
oh it's getting weird though
still up a pawn
play
h3 first
down a lot of time
trying to go for the mating attack
going for this now
oh this is a funny line
always play bishop f1 checkmate
can black stop it i don't think black
can stop it
opponent was trying to act like nigel
shorts
okay
bishop f1 would have
allowed king g4 there
okay got the job done
yeah queen g3
would delay the inevitable
okay
what's your favorite disney
movie uh
[Music]
i don't know
finding nemo
finding nemo maybe
not to be confused with nemo the chest
streamer
okay
uh
let's keep it going almost top hundred
i'll play a knight's tango
yeah like tango it's pretty
straightforward blitz opening
going for the ventral e5 i do concede
the bishop here but
the goal is to get some
some sort of like king's indian position
i want to play e4 here but
just move back
and
yeah knight h4 is maybe coming
and getting these structures a decent
amount lately
f4
f4 makes a lot of sense actually
if i take
because the pawn's attacked if rook
takes maybe knight g495
there's also queen takes
yeah this bishop is very menacing
so the goal is to play this and f6 and
just be solid
and e4 is kind of a backwards pawn
f6 here
if ever knight of five i have to take it
which i think is okay
oh thank you it's just time
i love your words
i also love my knights
idea
maybe 93.
uh
not sure if it does much damage though
also go for a4
that allows take some v4
it's hard to attack the pawn with my
knight here
so maybe this move
doesn't do much
i don't know what to do
i'll just play this hitting the pawn
maybe maybe this calls for more slow
play like queen e7 double up the rooks
the benefit of the knight here is if g4
i have potentially knight h4
always return to e5 if necessary
yeah i'm happy with this structure
oh
h5h6 is maybe coming
am i in time to take the pawn probably
not
h6 is going to be a pain
but it actually just makes the position
more spicy
h6 maybe queen g4 hitting g3
if it takes live knight t3
um yeah i'll play this move unleashing
the rooks preventing h6
maybe this move
ah that's why king h2 was played
well this is going to be slightly
painful
king h8
if takes i have knight g5
okay this with a double attack
i'll still go for queen a4
yeah the a pawns are potential targets
wow quindy1 want a move
of this move
goal is to open the h file for my rook
okay now i can take on e4
idea f5
oh i miss that move
it's not over though i still gotta get
in f5 and e6 is weak
now i have a monster knight white might
end up stacking back
it's also just coming down to time here
queen d5 i have knight f6
um gee
i don't know what to do here
in this
move
queen b2
oh good move queen of f8
gotta play quicker
that's a fork
okay
just quick enough there that was a good
game good fight
man
i'm sure there are miss things
throughout the game
okay five wins in a row let's go
close to top hundred
back to the bread and butter
and london opening time
yeah unfortunately c4 isn't as strong in
this line
so i'll probably go for a more
positional approach which is bishop d3
it's kind of uh the more boring type of
london but
um
maybe i can make it spicy
go for some e4 move
c3 there's queen e2
[Music]
probably end up playing both moves
eventually
okay
yeah the queen is actually
the queen just doesn't move
neither five is interesting so i could
take on a6
it's kind of a greedy move just
winning a random pawn but
okay imagine queen c and i just moved
back to c4
and lights up a pawn
there's also queen e7
so i would have to move back to c4 to
cover a2
okay so black gives a queen
he choose hanging
now i have
queen and pawn for rook and bishop
there's a move queen uh
queen b5
which actually looks kind of nice
just trying to simplify
so if takes i take the bishop and
pressure some things
and there is rook a6 here
then probably knight c5
okay so we're really trading down
still a question
how to convert
there's a line i'm looking at
it looks really wrong
but i don't see how i get punished and
if it works it just simplifies
so the point is after takes takes rook
d1 king h2 takes
queen b7
and then there's some back rank issues
for black
oh we're not going into that
i'll still play king h2
knight f3 will come next
component one's knight g4
i have this move
this move might actually be good oh but
then
i take on f2
okay i gotta move quicker
moving too slowly
the position is actually still a bit
tricky
so h5 is coming
i have this move
hitting both things
okay rook c5 i have b4
i don't see how black defends
and the bonus if
black goes for counter attack i take and
defend the knights
uh
i shouldn't be thinking here
this is a cute move
rick takes b2 i take on d3
it's still hitting the bishop
i probably want to play g4 and then go
from mate
i'm subjecting myself to discoveries but
it's okay
oh no my knight
checkmate
okay
i was pleasant
uh that was the reason for playing g4
back to tournament
hey tom 90.
yeah i was struggling to break into the
top 200 for a while but
now i'm on a six-game win streak
seven game no loss tree because i had
that one draw
try and keep it up
again lap is working
c5
enjoyed against this
it just takes
bishop d2
try and go for something simple and
solid
dc4
and this looks pretty pleasant
a nice space advantage
i'm getting better pawn structure too
so i can win the d6 pawn
i think i'll just gradually build up
though
hey it's colin roddy
thanks so much
welcome back
takes takes
yeah we'll simplify a bit
put the bishop in the center
[Music]
actually maybe rook yeah rook d1 and
then eventually taking rook d6
i'm trying to win another pawn
if king f6 i can
choose what to take with
we'll see how incredibly fast my
opponent is
wait wait wait whoa whoa almost
blundered at night i forgot the rook's
defended
so if i take with knight
yeah the rook can't be attacked
knight controls these squares it's a
little bit awkward but
um
yeah it's completely okay i
think now i can take
hit the rook
win another pawn
find a safe place for the king
win a rook
okay
another smooth game
75
up 75th place and 50 tournament points
a leader has 110
wow yeah this is a support nick
strong player
oh i'm playing a strong player
like georgiev
london opening time
oh joe bava london opening time
uh i'll take him play six
i had this earlier actually got a bad
position earlier
g4 so soon
i want to punish this move
wait what's the point after
queen v6
because g5 i think i just take the pawn
ah but then knight a4 oh it gets murky
knight a4 maybe queen a3
the queen before there would be c3
attacking defending and still attacking
the queen a3 i think
is okay knight b6 i have queen b4
winning the night
so still c3 now i have time to
save the knight
hitting the
pawn i'd love to play e5 e5 is like a
very thematic move
blow up the center
queen b3
can i still play e5
there's also e6
wait then knight
knight b6 is annoying
yeah i think i go for e5
man
looks wrong though
but it's it's an intuitive decision
queen d5
and i guess knight c3
so one of the benefits i cut off the
bishop from covering b8 so i do have
rook b8s
if necessary i could also take the
bishop
take the bishop take the pawn
[Music]
okay it's a risk but let's go for it
i'm dreaming of trapping the rook
someday if we trade queen then there's a
threat of bishop b2
and this knight and there's knight c7
which i forgot about
then king
d8 king of one
if i take the bishop
i think i'll simplify a little bit
bishop h3 the bishop is defended by my
queen through x-ray division
it's kind of cool and the idea is to
take and play digit d6
and the king is completely stuck and
or that rook is completely stuck as well
and i defend the pawn white's pieces are
all kind of just stuck
i'm still down the exchange
okay very oh i just plundered a pawn
ah
f3 maybe
oh that was not a good pawn to blunder
i guess f3
now the f4 coming
i gotta move much quicker too
this is okay
two pawns for the exchange
good move
so it takes i have this move
which might save me hitting this and
this
nice response
this move
tactics are wild this game
let's go okay
had to
unleash the pre-moves there man
it's it's so difficult to just stay like
focused
and just let intuition take over but
the tactical sequence was insane
like starting in this position so first
of all he found this like cool
positional idea to
win my f3 pawn and then this happened
hitting the rook
and obstructing the rook from defending
the knight and then he found this move
um
and i don't have time to take the knight
because of the rook kings and if i take
the rook then the knight is saved
but then i found this move
checking the king hitting the rook
and the lights defended through x-ray
vision
and then i went back to exchange
i had this funny move knight g3 because
the pawn was a bit overworked
and i was up a pawn i was down a ton of
time
and then somehow i didn't end up
plundering anything here
although i probably did but
like most of those moves had to be
pre-moves
okay
so the win streak continues
54 tournament points 67 place
playing eddie marsala
ah this line okay
so this is like a somewhat well-known
line
oh i supposed to play c5 first i think
maybe it's still playable
no i've
i've botched the opening ah and i kicked
my tripod
uh
so e4 is coming that's a big problem
if i play
actually maybe queen a from 25 quinn d2
i play d4
g4 is a funny move
i'm gonna play d4
opponents
clearly well prepared
okay let's go for this
hi eric i have liked enjoyed your
streams for 16 months now thanks for the
great content oh thank you
this position confuses me i have upon e3
which is probably gonna fall someday
but then again
it's not so simple i'm probably winning
c5
i wrote d3
if i take
i'll be down the pawn i have the bishop
hair though
moving really slowly in the opening
h5
the rook is almost trapped
hitting e3
i don't know which rook to move
oh no my bishop
please take it
actually how does white defend
so now i have this and then this pawn
will
oh there's rook c3 though or rook b3
i'll play h5
that's a good decision to keep the rook
here
h5 is a nice resource
so now i'm threatening
okay now i definitely have this move
oh no my rook
okay so now i'm up two pawns
pretty good after a
questionable opening
okay plenty of time to convert this
you just have to knock it
forked close to chopping the knight
almost got forged there
it still probably would have been
winning though
okay so the goal is to put the king on a
square where it's hard for the knight to
check
it feels like i'm playing against myself
this opponent is not resigning
okay
let's go
got the job done another win
top 60 now
58 tournament points
will this arena go on youtube
uh
maybe the future youtube viewers can
answer that question
if you're watching in the future and
you've made it to this point
let me know if this video made its way
to youtube
okay playing cuban let's play
more chess
i'll play modern
oh i'll play um
just play some simple line h3
bishop d3
ah tricky tricky
even some like opening crop idea
it's still very stable position
okay tickling the pawn
and now the other pawn
i don't think i want to take that
actually
like we need to maybe go for c4
thank you thing duster
yeah the idea is to
some some point play c4
and the black king doesn't have like a
great place to go
i want to play bishop f4 rook d1
so bishop f4 there's 93
so maybe bishop g5
id is still work d1
oh i don't want to trade queens but i
might have to
there is this move though
so the idea is if takes i take first and
then
e7 will hopefully be weak
wow
i mean i'll have too many options here
it's moving a bit too slowly
idea a4 if or a5 if black plays a5 i
have bishop e3
yeah some unusual pawn structure here
rook a4
rook here
rook d5 is probably coming
not an easy position to play
black is clearly for choice here
but it's still a fight
i mean knight d3 king e3
that's a good move
really ugly move
okay
there's some potential meeting idea
let's start with b4
um
this move now
do this move
this might actually been the night
took a lot of time to find that but
looks like i'm winning material
hey hey
okay now i want to meet
it's really close to mating rook g5 only
move
oh i didn't see that move
ah
did you play king h1
it's such a funny mating idea too
wow king h1 threatening mate
well i can't stop it because i control
all these squares
and there's rook g3 but oh black can't
stop it i have this
move all i want to do is mate
rook e3
it's so funny these pawns are such
heroes
what does black do here
i don't see any moves for black
i just win the thing
and i'll meet
uh like this
there we go
oh that's such a cool position
it's so unusual to have
a back rank mate
where like these squares are not
occupied by black pawns
but the bishop and pawn is just
coordinated
spent a lot of time in this position
because i i wanted to play rook g1 this
was my original thought but then takes
and
i don't have a good place to put my king
because here there's check here there's
takes in
and the pawn falls in the end
um
so i took 20 seconds
out of my 49 seconds to play king g3
which one material
and then
yeah then king h1 is
such a nice kind of
it looks like a defensive move it's just
defending made in one
and rookie three was uh
icing on the cake
okay back to tournament
the win streak continues
i've lost count how many games i've won
in a row
um i guess it helps on not berking
just trying to stay calm oh bishop e5 is
the main move
i got confused
95 here
hitting the knight
oh did i mess up
well maybe it's still playable
at a five yeah
i know this is a thing
lee
there's a really funny line here
i don't think it works though i'm
calculating here here here
takes queen h596 i take
i don't think it works
normally i would go for something like
that but
maybe i start with queen h5
setting up the idea of bishop e5 e6
i'm black can just play e6 though so
or that move
um i want to play a4
yeah queen h5 was
kind of a waste of time
sorry to say
though maybe i have e4 here
okay we'll be a little bit spicy
the knight g7 back would be funny
the idea is okay i might lose a few
pawns but i have bishop b5 in the end
black one is none of it
it's now taken
probably not see four
let's see four blunders a piece
just take some queen b4
bishop c4
bishop c4
yeah looks more interesting
okay i have to castle queenside
f7 is still
hanging would then defend a2 in the
event of if takes i have this move or
this move
the bishop is kind of stuck actually
um
throw in
maybe f4 first
preserving my check possibilities
g3
okay pleasant position now
you can take here
yeah so i just want to mate now
turning b7
block finds a way to defend but
not really
in rook takes e5 i have queen d6
king b1
playing it safe
uh playing it very safe
safety first
yeah very risk-free chess
okay another one down
42nd place
yeah maybe i should not berserk more
often i was thinking at the beginning
i i had a slow start because i wasn't
berserking but
helps to be playing good quality chess
another london opening
yeah this is
it feels like i'm playing myself
actually bishop b5 trendy line
um the move is rook c8 i believe
i have to remember what to do here
like queen
queen b6 and a6 or something
very topical lion
i know the queen is supposed to go here
at some point
maybe right away
so i have the bishop here
i have a slightly weak pawn here
slightly behind the development too
but apart from that
as long as i can play bishop b7 castling
hopefully it's okay
a4
bishop b4 is tempting
then queen b3
will be safe
i don't see white's idea
with a4a5 ah that's idea
my bishop can come
probably to d5
moving slowly again
okay so fix the structure
or it has a queen side majority and 29
years old in three days cheers
thanks t kong
this d4 pawn is a little bit ooh
okay well i have this move
uh yeah this is slightly terrifying
um
queen b7 may be necessary
it feels really cramped here
okay i'll redevelop the bishop ideology
seven eventually
or knight h5 i guess
trying to have some activity
so keep in mind h6
at the right moment
bishop d6
bishop can actually return to a happy
place
it's hard for white to make progress
question is what to do now
a little bit stuck for ideas
h5h4
allows bishop e3
might be interesting
all right should be on h8
fancy move
i should put the rook on h8
now or later
a bit later
id e5 and queen h3
very sharp position though
let's try it down to a7 which is nice
g4 f9 f4 or even right h2
going for it
let's start with this keep that f4 for
later
a lot of things for white to worry about
here
take
maybe take here first with check
take and take
the very least i should win the rook on
h2
that's all i need
ah
tricky doll rook c7
take this
okay
oh
opponent tricked me towards the end
i was just quick enough
okay
another win
yeah that was a kind of intense game
i thought i was getting smushed and then
i unswished myself
and i had to go for the flag at the end
so still 42nd place playing chess coal
um i'll take the time odds
i'm playing reverse bononi
uh maybe h3 there's also a
five a few moves to choose from
the h6
i should have prevented that
maybe this move
can i take the pawn
i think it's just a trade but i have
knight b3 in the end
winning material and if queen b1 i take
on c1
i can still take on c1 but i think this
is better
the bishop's now hanging
wow
so white's going full ham
um i mean i probably just take
don't see how white gives me problems
here
so i'm up a rook and a knight
for a pawn
okay bishop e4
yeah i'll just consolidate
maybe some f5
throw in the check
a few moves to choose from
i kind of like this move
ideas after takes i play queen f6
and then the bishop's tied down to
f7 or f2 i guess i allowed this
but i'm up a lot of material
okay
another nice game
34th place 74 tournament points
uh yeah pretty good result
especially given the
a slow start to the tournament
i've lost count of my win streak
still
opponent was working again
i haven't had a true stafford
will it happen
i'll still offer it
ah this line is considered dubious for
light
because of rookie gates
white might treat it as a gambit
yeah um
[Music]
do i actually want to take the pawn
it's actually
like there's vibes of the marshall
gambit actually
yeah this is like a reverse marshall
d4
i don't really play the marshall gambit
i feel like it's risky doing this but
we'll see
are you winning sun
in rose and t
i'm trying i'm trying
i'm all the pawn here
opponent doesn't have the usual like
queen h4
i have c5
probably this in queen f6
yeah i think a lot of my games is
tournament i'm just like
i'm accepting gambits rather than
playing gambits
maybe i should do that more often
calculating bishop f5 we trade in queen
d6
and d4
i forgot about that move i think it's
okay though
um
it's slightly unpleasant
it says bishop e5 after knight d2
what's going on there
the h6 first
wow
trade
yeah i really want a sack but
it's not called for
i love bishop c4
i'll get my knight to e5
it should be okay
i'm still up a pong
a little bit of lag there
always defend again if i need to
let's move first
be careful
targeting c3
go for queen trade or a win of the
exchange
oh
oh this is not good
okay
well the win streak continues
man
i'll take it i'll take it
78 tournament points this guy go
talk about trays
arena nonetheless this is top rate work
m rose and the title slayer oh thanks so
much thing duster
i'm playing wine egg
okay we'll play the line with knight d2
i had a similar position earlier
or i went for a cool idea to take and
play e4
maybe i'll go for it again he's cracked
let's go
let's go
[Music]
but this position is uncrackable
okay so i kind of just came up with this
idea today good luck eric against the
bishop f5
um
i think i can castle
and keep it positional
if i take
also c3 here
c3 hangs upon
if we trade in bishop e5
huh
i play c3
a lot of choices
you just rick p1
thank you matlock matt unbelievable
wait what
ah that's a move
um
if i take
knight d2
playing a little bit passively this game
now knight c4
oh no
oh no this is not good
i mean i have bishop d3
okay let's just go for this
should be five first
d4
hmm
h4
oh queen b6 is a threat i have this move
funny move
or it can come in
i'll speed things up
that's a good move
die blundered
yeah
this is not going to end well
ah there goes my win streak oh good game
though
pairings are closed
that's sad to end it on a loss but
overall pretty good tournament
getting some raiding
i was hoping to hit a new blitz peak
which i maybe did i hit a peak
let's
highest rating ever oh i hit my peak
january 8th let's go
new blitz peak